Oh boohoo Hillary Clinton seems to say
she's not running in 2020 but she is
running with the race card I was the
first person who ran for president
without the protection of the Voting
Rights Act and I will tell you it makes
a really big difference it made a
difference in Wisconsin where the best
studies that have been done said
somewhere between 40 and 80 thousand
people were turned away from the polls
because of the color of their skin well
guess what
The Washington Post gave her four
Pinocchios for that blatant lie
80,000 people turned away from polls
joining me now on this is so much more
renowned economist old friend Tom soul
senior fellow at the Hoover Institution
author of the phenomenal book
discrimination and disparities which is
now out in a revised enlarged edition
Tom thanks for being here why is Hillary
saying that I I think she knows it's not
true so why because she thinks he'll get
us some votes other than that that's the
reason politicians say a lot of things
that are true I mean Hillary Clinton so
many others are now talking about
reparations Trump's a racist it's a say
it's race race race race race the
immigration policies racist the race
word is the constant it's like abortion
and race in today's Democrat Party it is
I have the feeling that many Americans
would just as soon not hear any more
about race but there are people for whom
this is their ticket to whatever racket
they're running including the political
racket and it's tragic I what's tragic
is that there are so many people out
there who simply respond to words rather
than ask themselves is what it's what
this person says true how could I check
it and so on do you think that with that
you know just as small a case in Chicago
and now we have this r.kelly guy is
accused well I mean are Kelly's not
focusing on race but the smollett case
became one of
race and it was almost like there were
certain people out there who were
disappointed when it seemed like this
thing was a big hoax they wanted this to
be a racial incident a racial hate crime
reinforcing the stereotype set this is
what's wrong with society today the
overriding problem in society today is
one of race Tom well you know it's like
in football they're gonna run that play
until someone font someone finds a way
to stop it and as long as it pays off
they're gonna keep doing it what's
painful to me is how few people there
are today who bother to check out the
facts in many cases just the smallest
effort at checking out the facts would
cause so many of these things to fall
apart and we have a whole history of
this going back to the Torah so tirana
ball
Broly woman back in the nineteen
something's and then the Duke Lacrosse
case so there been any number of these
things but as long as they keep
succeeding politically they'll they'll
continue to run that play do you think
president Trump would do well to make
like monthly trips to underserved more
underprivileged areas or to
traditionally black colleges communities
of color where he can just talk about
why his policies are working and why the
economy is growing opportunities jobs
greater employment etc what would you
recommend that he die I don't I don't
think that that the venue matters that
much but there has to be some sort 'full
notions about how free markets and other
kinds of activities that are different
from what would have normally heard how
those things impact and I don't see any
sign of that of on a need of any
significance unfortunately from the
Republicans I never cease to be amazed
at how many opportunities they let go by
right now for example Democrats around
the country are lining up to stop
charter schools from expanding try to
cut back on them
these many of them are the very schools
that are most successful are the ones
they're zeroing in places like success
academy or Kipp schools and so forth and
the Democrats I understand they have to
do that because they beholden to the
teachers unions but why the Republicans
don't say anything about it that is what
baffles me naturally pro-choice
initiatives that actually help
individuals instead of just focusing on
blocks of individuals dr. Sol aoc
Alexandre Castillo Cortez she has spoken
a lot about socialism and being a
Democrat socialist now she's a young
person twenty eight years old but she's
she is representing a decent chunk of
the Democrat Party today I want to play
something for you and have you react
let's watch when Millennials talk about
concepts like Jenner like democratic
socialism we're not talking about these
kind of Red Scare boogeyman we're
talking about single-payer health care
we're talking about tuition free public
colleges and universities we're talking
about a living wage we're talking about
guaranteed basic levels of dignity this
sounds good to a lot of young people and
this focus group from CNN we just
alluded to and they seem very excited
about these concepts what are
Republicans not doing the Republicans
are not saying anything that I've heard
of course all these things sound
wonderful it's just that we now have
more than half a century of knowledge of
a track record of these kinds of ideas
being put into practice in countries
around the world and failing time and
time again not merely failing but making
things worse that they were they were
before Venezuela is the classic case and
yet during the whole period when people
are starving in Venezuela under
socialism the young people are right out
of our colleges flocking to Bernie
Sanders because they're judging by his
words and how wonderful it sounds and
not not by what happens when you try to
put those notions into practice as has
been tried again in countries in Europe
Asia Africa South everywhere this
this is like that word and repeat failed
experiment we've ever seen dr. Tom soul
it is so great to see it tonight
come back soon love your books somebody
my friend thank you very much
tell them we're such huge fans